like I don't find the hookup culture
really I feel like that's getting phased
out if anything I mean the thing is you
can get everything so easily now right
you used to like actually have to go to
a like have any of you ever gone to a
bar by yourself and just like sat at the
bar and if a guy and seen if a guy like
hits on you or even just has a drink
have a drink by yourself like in the old
days like if you were meeting a friend
at the bar at the movies before you had
a phone right like you had to stand
there and then you would and then you
would people watch you'd actually just
like look at people and like we've just
sort of devolved all of that so our
brains are just never not hooked into
the Matrix and I think that that's added
to a lot of the kind of loneliness and
crazies that it seems like a lot of
people in their 20s are feeling right
now